there are only three primary colors so
why do we have picassos why do we have
Mones why do we have Da Vinci really
everything that's ever been painted
should have already been painted and yet
somebody can take those three primary
colors and blend them in a way to create
an endless number of color effects you
can either see the limitations as the
reason why you don't innovate or you can
see those limitations as the material
from which you must innovate and one of
the powerful things with Innovation is
you're not necessarily trying to solve a
new problem you're trying to solve an
old problem that no longer can be solved
with an old solution so I don't feel
like everyone's already taken up all the
space you find a unique way to solve a
problem that everyone has it's going to
revolutionize everything